nochmals glück hat meine liebe freunde
ich habe heute davon machen wie heute
zur feier des tages etwas das hier
absolut keinen spaß macht denn wir
reagieren auf die hilfe folge atemlos
macht mir die helene sie peinlich so was
wie kann man da nur mitspielen
menschlich gesehen ziemlich abstoßend
und ich dachte ich kann nicht
schauspielern mein herz mein stopp
abbruch mein gehirn bitte nicht mein
finger here we go again die ersten
sekunden verstören mich stunden die der
titel sagt bin ich atemlos am ersticken
regie wie prinz soll es sein hilf mir ja
ja und an der stelle darf ich euch
herzlich willkommen heißt sie heute zu
einer neuen reaction von mir luca auf
hilf mir schnell teure gehirnzellen an
denn es geht nur noch bergab
ich starte das video und die sind direkt
im bett amrum lecken gärten helene
prozent was uns erst mal gucken was wir
heute als erstanden haben bei dem
zweiten treffen
beim fanclub treffen
wir hatten euch jetzt hirn geschissen
erstmals wichtigsten was haben die denn
so eine tasse mit herausdrehen ich
morgen erst mal einen kaffee
[Musik]
menschen sind ziemlich abstoßend t-shirt
ohne cap wunderschön wunderschön ja das
ist mir noch eingefallen was wir lehnen
machst mir nochmal die helene
man will jetzt singen oder war atemlos
durch die nacht ist ein neuer tag
die man nie vergisst um den blick ab
und ich dachte ich lag müll content hoch
was ist unsere die eltern kommen
habt ihr sie noch alle was meine hier
könnten
egal die tür stand
der weit aufgerückte aber nicht genug
hallo ich bin florian der freund von ihr
ab
endlich war
weil die eltern von seiner freundin oder
kommen die eltern da rein und sehen
nicht nur irgendwie wie er da sitzt du
café bringen wir da doch dann stellen
wir heute nacht tanzen zu atemlos durch
die nacht meine augen zeigen verschnitt
name dürfen das pfeifen das land gekauft
haben jetzt schon einiges klar gegen
florian ich glaube du hast schon ein
bisschen reingeschüttet allein das hätte
lieber einfach auch florian heißt zu der
freund von elena heißt auch florian oder
du wirst auch mal den mut haben muss man
auch geldgier
wenn man welcher welt lebt sie denn du
bist meine mutter du musst mir geld
geben dass sich war das ist nicht wahr
die heißt die linie das ist ich war der
sie heißt lena und ihr freund florian
das ist ihr habt den preis verdienen rtl
hatte nämlich sein gesicht ich ihnen
also die mitarbeiterinnen von ihr also
ihre kollegin ist ein bisschen abgefuckt
von ihr und ihrer beziehung aber der
florian hat eine überraschung für die
elena sie gehen raus sie wünsche ich im
büro sprechen so fort
da hat ja rule hat ein machtwort
gesprochen
kannst du mit der 300 euro mit raus
hey
ich habe der branche
wenn ich aber du müsstest 300 euro
mitbringen arbeit bitte gehen sie bitte
das können sie doch nicht ganz kurz das
köln
warum spielt diese scheiße in meinem
fall jede karte hilft ihr wollt gespielt
die geldnot touristen fest ich koche ich
bin okay weil ich dachte das wäre der
vater ich greife hier jeden tag den
arsch auf der nach halle gekommen um
mich gefreut grad geküsst habe
naja
ihr habt da so einen halben punkt per
faxwahl china gedreht
ich denke jetzt nur frankreich und china
kannst du mir vielleicht mindestens 50
euro leihen wäre ich zu passiv
ja so wie die ina grad cook soll das
denke ich mir auch gerade selber bis zu
120eur unterricht ihr könnt ja auch
irgendwas machen was kein geld und
müssen manchmal so gefährlich
er redet die welt die einfach keine 50
euro geben weil sie es nicht kann die
dinger duo euro ok oder kann überhaupt
schon wieder kommen lena lena ist völlig
kopflos nur weil florian gesagt hat sie
soll geld mitbringen clouds wie an ihrem
arbeitsplatz
da haben wir es wieder man man braucht
diese pädagogen zehn milliarden menschen
nicht dass das hier ein bisschen zu
teuer ist
was hast du es gilt dabei dass er klar
408 419 als gedacht die kenne ich wusste
ich kann man sich verlassen was mal ganz
kurz
er hat eine überraschung für sie und die
besteht daraus dass sie sich jetzt eine
schönheits op machen lässt thomas anders
ticken was denkst du wie das ist fast so
gut aus wie lenny fischer
wenn du heute hier fertig bist ein
schatz dann komme ich zwar nicht
unterscheiden
sie soll
sich komplett zu
helene fischer
seht ihr das niveau geht ja auch nicht
sehr viel von sich preis ich habe
irgendwie das gefühl der verstehen das
glauben wir auch
wir müssten mal rauskommen oder wohnt
und immer willig gut dass der bruder von
der elena und die arbeitskollegin mal
ein bisschen was über den florian
erfahren wollen und dem ganzen auf die
schliche gehen wenn sie mit mir kommen
ja du dich dann schick machen es ja noch
das passende outfit für dich
hey
rauber kriegt man da einen silbereisen
im griff bitte um schnelle meiner
freundin geben fuhr dort sofort angst
und ich will sie auf keinen fall sehen
vor so komplett fertig umgezogen ist ja
alles klar machen
okay der floriade was einkaufen was sie
lehnen sich anziehen sollten jetzt
schauen wir uns mal enes finale helene
verwandlung einschätzt und was sagst du
ich finde ich sie sieht ein bisschen aus
wie soll der christbaumkugel gott
alleine kein kursrisiko verschmiert doch
damit das make up
verschmiert ja dann
ich frage mich immer noch ob der florian
nicht irgendwie hintenrum noch eine böse
absicht hat sind aber eben auch zu 200
euro die 400 euro
hast du hast du nichts übrig von den
cameron natürlich genau zwei euro
[Musik]
egal
wer
nein
genommen und ihren geschickt und so
wunderschön wie die unsere lena raiders
extrem kurzes geld
was schaue ich mir an kommt dass uns
gehen das war's
was ist
es ist mit dem bruder damit der ina ich
hoffe dass euch diese hilfe reaction
nach einigen monaten mal wieder gefallen
hat wenn es das getan hat das gern einen
daumen anderen knoten
[Musik]